this is the eighth annual list of
america's richest self-made women and
the theme this year
was sort of persistence and
entrepreneurial success in spite of the
headwinds from the downturn in the stock
market overall as a group these 100
entrepreneurs and executives and
entertainers
are
worth about six percent less than last
year when we did the list so all
together they're worth 111 billion
dollars um we had a bunch of people drop
off
because stock prices dropped or the
value of private companies dropped so
you know we've got interesting stories
about women
who are you know building and starting
and growing all kinds of companies we've
got seven newcomers this year one of
them is lucy blow who was on the forbes
under 30 list
she and um a guy named alexander wang
co-founded
an artificial intelligence company
called scale ai lucy
held on to her
stake in scale ai
when she left the company in 2018 she's
since founded a venture capital firm
back end capital and then
she started this spring a stealth
web 3 company that she's she's building
um she's worth 440 million dollars and
she is young she's only 27 years old
another newcomer is a woman who's not
well known but tied to very well-known
people emma greed
has a a tight role with the kardashian
folks she is a co-founding partner of
kim kardashian's
shapewear and loungewear company skims
she's the chief product officer there
her stake in that company where her
husband is the ceo i should say
is probably the biggest chunk of her net
worth she's also the ceo of a fashion
line called good american and she's owns
part of a company with kris jenner
another newcomer to this is rachel drory
some of you may have read about her
before in forbes she is the founder of a
meal delivery service that is
plant-based called daily harvest and
it's uh the company raised money from
investors
um in the past year which landed her on
the list
she has a great story she was sort of
doing this as a side hustle
while working another job and when she
got more customers who were not friends
and family and she made a go of it
so number one on this list for the fifth
year in a row is diane hendricks
she's not really a household name except
if you're a fan of this list she is
the co-founder of a roofing and building
supply company called abc supply she
co-founded it with her husband who sadly
passed away in 2007 she is worth 12.2
billion dollars revenues at the company
really surged in 2021 amid this boom in
housing number two on this list is judy
faulkner the founder of epic which is a
electronic health records company
that is private and she it owns a big
chunk of that she is worth 6.7 billion
dollars so one one of the things that's
happened because the the stock market
route that we had this spring two of the
women on the list who were billionaires
a year ago still on the list but no
longer billionaires the first is whitney
wolf heard
the ceo and co-founder of dating app
bumble one other women who i think
deserves special attention is betsy
cohen she's new to the list this year
she's 80 years old and she was one of
the first women in the united states
to co-found and become ceo of a bank
she's more recently been investing in
finance through the spax the special
purpose acquisition companies that
became so popular during the earlier
part of the pandemic we had seven women
that came back onto the list this year
who had been on the list in prior years
fell off and are now making a return the
most well-known of those is rhys
witherspoon who's got this uh production
actress famous actress um of course but
she's also become a director and a
relics an executive in her company hello
sunshine which
produces uh produced big little lies and
and others she's got investment in hello
sunshine from outside investors that
increase the value of the company
you